[Music]
good evening I'm Alexander Rose the
executive director at the long now
foundation as many of you know we start
these talks with a long short a short
film that in some way exemplifies
long-term thinking and often we we cheat
and use things like time lapses
tonight's is a little different but
before I introduce that I just wanted to
mention there is a whole other series
now going on that long now is producing
at our smaller venue the interval this
Friday we have a 5 p.m. kind of a social
hour talk with Rachel Sussman who
formerly spoke in this series on her
project photographing organisms that
have lived longer than 2000 years all
over the world and her book is just now
coming out and we'll be hearing another
talk from her as well as she'll be doing
a book signing
that's Friday in Fort Mason and
afterwards you can go to get your dinner
at off the grid from all the trucks and
Tuesday we have violet blue speaking
about her newest book smart girls guide
to privacy and she has all kinds of good
tips for how to not let your digital
data go out into the world so tonight's
tonight's long short is actually by
someone who has I believe agreed to give
a talk in this series when he walks by
in about 5 years and he started his walk
out of Africa a little over a year ago
this this is a description of his
project from right before he left he's
he he emailed us from Israel where he is
now and gave us permission for this this
video and and they are actually
soliciting support for their effort
and there's a there's a URL at the end
to help get them through the next or him
through walking the entire out of Africa
track
down to down through the Americas over
the course of seven years enjoy next
year I'm taking a long walk retracing
our ancestors first great migration
across the planet starting in our
birthplace the Rift Valley of East
Africa and walking north through the
Levant and then eastward across the
gravel plains of Asia to our to Siberia
from where I'll hop a boat to the
Americas and ramble down the western
flank to Patagonia the last corner of
the world where ancestors ran out of
horizon I'm a journalist and I'm trying
really hard to return to a more human
pace of storytelling not just jetting in
and out of assignments but walking with
people digging deep into crucial stories
that we miss because we're all moving
too fast to listen
[Music]
I'm as worried as anyone about the
troubles we face a century ahead climate
change resource shortages mass
migrations war our ancestors also
overcame huge obstacles in their primal
journey across the world whether it was
Ice Ages or massive epidemics or famines
my long journey will be difficult I'm
not so naive to believe that the world
can't kill you in an instant it can in
my experience when you slow down people
tend to open up to you the world it's
home after all
[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart Brandon from the
long now foundation the long now
foundation adores deserts I think it's
because the long now adores deserts
because when you go into the desert you
step out of biological to step out a
cultural time you step on the biological
time and you step into geological time
and things in deserts is the water isn't
there anymore our incredibly well
preserved partly because there's no
water to rot them and various kinds of
traffic to wear them down partly because
humans don't go there anymore because
the water is not there if you want the
long view of the long horizon the desert
has large quantities of that step during
tough storms our speaker tonight has
been dealing with the best of all of
Earth's deserts the Sahara is bigger
than anything you look at Earth from
space and big events are Antarctica the
oceans and the big brown amazing event
of North Africa so everything's south of
the Mediterranean all the way down to
Central Africa is just one single
enormous unexplored uninhabited event
that has been an event at various times
in human history and is again in various
respects and when our speaker looks at
things out there when the very few
explorers go there and look at things
out there they're often looking at
things that nobody's looked at or
thought about and thousands of years
that's what geological time is like to
experience to examine and to dissect and
analyze and then think about and use it
the best at that is our speaker Stephan
Brooklyn
[Applause]
Thank You Stuart hello everyone
that's the sound work okay thank you
because this fell out of my pocket so
I'm going to talk tonight
on my favorite subject the Sahara and
particularly on the mysterious desert
crater
hidden in the deep Sahara the Sahara has
Stuart just mentioned is a largest hot
desert on earth it covers almost about
the size of the United States nine
million square kilometres so one
lifetime is not not good enough to know
at least a part of it and of course the
Sahara doesn't exist as many Sahara's is
like a big difference between the
Canadian border and Florida and the East
Coast states and California and the same
applies to the Sahara of course so I'm
focusing on the eastern Sahara which to
the present day probably is the least
explored part of the of this big desert
and even a hundred years ago it was
practically completely unexplored as you
see on this atlas from 1922 and so it's
a big opportunity for geologists and to
your archaeologists like mine of really
going still these days on research
frontiers and that's part of the sites
we've and I've been working during the
past certified year so each red spot can
stay for a few days but it can also
stand for a few months or fieldwork and
this was only possible within the scope
of several large-scale long-term
research projects called collaborative
research centers which provided the
logistics and the possibilities to work
in these remote places
this is a outline of what I'm going to
talk so first I will talk about [ __ ] on
the working conditions which are be
different from geological worsens our
work in some other of places on the
globe and then I will provide you a few
examples of outstanding sites but there
it's just a very short selection of
sites I could show you if there would be
more than an hour and finally I will try
to condense everything into short
synthesis and conclusion on the origin
so going to your study area sometimes
take weeks and months and there's no
tracks because the Eastern Sahara is
practically devoid of wells and near
surface groundwater there's no bed winds
as in the central western part of Sisera
that means there are practically no
tracks and you always have have to find
your own way and especially during the
pre GPS period there was sometimes a bit
complicated you have to carry everything
you can and for example this a few car
babish Bedouins were the only people we
met you in the first ten years of
fieldwork in the Eastern Sierra where
the last prehistoric people left some
5000 years ago and most places you go
you're the first human Homo sapiens who
returns to the sides and sometimes you
have to drive down quite steep slopes
sometimes you have to climb up
escarpment of a couple of hundred metres
which takes sometimes a whole day just
to get two vehicles up building your oat
your author wrote using sent letters
sometimes you have to shovel away half a
dune and prepare your own Road to find a
descent down an escapement in some
places
well that's daily sports this is
sticking out your vehicular switch is
particular difficult in salty Marsh
deposits which near surface ground water
sometimes the whole fleet got
thank in the like he and the great
sensei of Egypt where sometimes the cars
are stuck 50 times in a row and in the
evening you know what you've done but
certainly no research these days and
immerses if you have 26th on trunk get
sunk in some sort of muddy salt deposits
and and you can go on it for some while
until it breaks down and unloading 18
tons of payload and getting three
vehicles out out of it made our day or
the last day of 1980s real so sometimes
you have to build your own Road just to
get down from from plateaus into the for
land without knowing whether you will
make it out again because sometimes if
for example our well he gets blocked and
you're down with the cars and you have a
serious problem
and sometimes it gets dusty most people
don't like it we like it because these
are weathered paleo Lake deposits
so-called
fresh fish deposits and the second later
you wouldn't see the car anymore
sometimes we have kind of mechanical
problems like in this case where the
back axis of our unimog was cut like
with a laser beam 100 kilometers away
from the Nile and what we could do is
use a backhoe shovel as a force wheel
and make walk the last 50 miles back to
the Nile Valley sometimes visibility is
quite bad like this a few years ago
where we had a one week long dust storm
which is much more difficult than
sandstorms because then normally it
doesn't fly higher than two meters above
ground so on a camel on top of the car
you are you're easy while driving for a
week with such visibility of just a few
yards poses some problems except
especially if you have to cross dune
fields the biggest problem in the past
few years when since our paradise of
fools were with where we stayed up to
six months in in a row in Wow
without meeting a single person two days
of course insecurity and normally you
only find out very last minute that sees
for example is a detachment official
detachment of the Chadian army and not
rebels if this would have been rebels or
bandits I might not be here for this
lecture today and even worse are the
landmines which are widely distributed
in the excess owns to our study areas in
the central Sahara usually remains bad
remains from the Libyan war with chart
for example where you're not supposed to
leave one track and me going in front
that's one of the rare occasions where
all my colleagues are really following
in my track track directly which is also
normally not often the case if you're
unlucky then you hit an anti-tank mine
to cut a long story short two passengers
were not hurt with a miracle but a few
minutes later nothing of this brand-new
Mercedes car where were just some liquid
aluminum and going there of course you
find you have to find a campsite every
night because usually geologists are
Bedouin so we move into our normally we
get over quickly done so preferred
campsites are in the in the downwind
side of this large Peconic dunes which
can weigh up to hundreds of thousand
tons which are transported by the wind a
couple of metres up to eight meters a
year so still not unless we're under
stood physical features and of course
and no everybody knows it's quite hot in
Sahara sometimes plus more than 50
degrees in in in the shade and of course
there is little shade so if you forgot
to take your foot underneath the car
then you gotta heavily sunburned with it
minutes on the other end much worse the
cold nights which with including the
chill factor which cool can cool down in
the winter seasoned and that's the only
time of the year when you can work to
felt minus 20 degree cells is I don't
know
that exact him Fahrenheit but believe me
it's cold and that's our that's our
kitchen if you if there's some sin stone
and you forget to close our kitchen then
there's a room for for some cleaning up
next time so enough with it our that was
takes up a high percentage of our work
in the Sahara so when I was young I
thought well one day a preparation is
needed for one hour of serious fieldwork
sometimes in between I got that one week
is necessary from writing proposals down
to getting the permits and customs and
transport and so on for one hour but
anywhere there's a very low relation
between the work you have to put on
logistic just to get to these remote
areas our field methods I'm not talking
about lab methods this would be another
lecture but and we are studying more
than 50 different proxies as we say to
find our taylor climate but the most our
favorite time is is sticking holes
either using such small mechanical
excavators like this one and then
digging a few yard deep holes where you
can take the samples and look for
archaeological remains etc which is much
better than taking course and if not
possible then just taking a whole and
and and and go in and look what you find
at the base that's geologists sometimes
we we already dug six seven meter deep
holes and that was what I've seen the
whole day taking the section that was
just the hole in the top that's in the
central Sahara and other interesting
more easier work is worth taking up
stratigraphy that means layers of
deposits of former now long extinct
lakes and rivers and playa lakes and
this is one of the sides for the
archaeologists a lot of time has to be
spent for surveying or for mapping any
sites and that's a large priest
excite we're at the first tight few
people would think that there's anything
left archaeologic excavate excavations
are extremely time-consuming like here
in the Great Sea of of sensi or
sometimes you need a couple of weeks
just to excavate a few square meters but
every excavation means destruction that
means to to have to resource this big
puzzle aware of the kind of artifacts
which have been produced at this site
and to tell who did it what skills did
he have in which direction was the wind
blowing and so on you have to take this
time not not to lose any possible
information to your best of conscience
excavating one new Alisa gray for
example can also take one week for four
to five archaeologists the same applies
to remains like this elephant jaw
embedded in paler Lake deposits which is
also it's not just taking it out and
sampling it but getting all the
information possible so now why do all
this kind of work and the first replies
of course academic it's first of all to
say well a do the ocean ocean cause and
the ice cores from the polar region
tells the whole story for climate change
on the continents and that's in the in
the end where people are living used to
be living and will be living in the
future and as a man is neither fish nor
penguin the important information comes
has to come from terrestrial
paleoclimatology and there's many things
for example which were that the Holocene
the post glacial period of the past
eleven thousand years was consistent
based on polar research as a most stable
period as you will see in the Sahara the
opposite was the case another hypothesis
which was based on ocean core taken by
my good friend Peter Dominica from
Lamont in in New York was that he was
claiming by analyzing or interpreting
ocean cause that that the onset of the
green Sahara have
within decades within one generation and
is the same that's what he claimed was
his desiccation of the entire Sahara of
what he called the the African humid
period happened also in a few decades
and that was well which didn't go along
with our data which we've been
collecting and of course that general
approach is to see how climate and
environmental change change the social
economic way of life of the prehistoric
dwellers in what is today hyper arid
desert and whether that included
cultural change and whether that
Aldridge brought some some evolution
which is important to to Africa to the
present day
and so paler climatology is always more
amazing that's why I oughta my friend
ray Bradley put it on the leading
textbook on paler climatology once
humans are in paler climatology without
humans as is a bit less exciting and of
course I recently stumbled on this quote
from Stewart the urchin keeps displacing
the important in our daily lives and
that made me think why on earth why
someone like me who goes into the desert
for more than forty years spent there a
couple of months every year there must
be some some hidden motivation if not
probably you wouldn't do it and some
people only go once and never again and
there's many many things which come to
my mind I'm a first of all you have in
your campsite in the night you have a
360 degree horizon around you and and
you hear the blood in your way in some
Bedouin say you can even listen to your
bones and you hear the metroid if you
have some metric going down in the night
you you hear the sound when there's no
wind there's absolute
saluté a quiet you
of course you you stop being a consumer
like in the Western world that consuming
agent more or less because there's
nothing you could buy and so on the same
as money loses any importance because
the only thing it's good for when you
stay months without meeting any people
is maybe to light a fire of course
there's no internet and so so does your
whole existence which in one way loses
any importance under this hotel of a
million stars which you have any night
when there's no sandstorm and and
staying outside so listening thinking
about these daily problems finding a
parking lot they sound so absurd once
you're in a place we have nine
kilometres of parking lot available and
it's difficult to explain that to some
of the few remaining local people there
and on the other hand your own existence
gains a lot of value because a map any
single drop of water it's a miracle more
or less and in the morning you you have
a sympathy when it as a slightly frozen
scorpion crawling out under your
sleeping bed so you would never have the
idea to kill it because he survived you
survived another cold night or stormy
night and and he's trying to do his life
as you do so sources there's a sort of
symbols sympathy which may sound crazy
to you but that's really one of the of
the motivations you have and so of
course a desert a timeless and there we
also end the one along now subject it's
probably the state it's a fate of the
planet everything will become desert
like the surface of Mars and so on so
it's it's without time and again while
before so I start with it before I
become to get too philosophical that's
really I think it's no wonder that most
religions originated in deserts where
Yuri confronted
yourself and now I'm showing you a few
examples one comes from the give kabir
big sandstone plateau in the
southwestern corner of egypt south of of
the great sand sea of Egypt and ufc's
almost thousand-mile my long language
you'd need use up to hundred meters high
which which run into the sandstone
plateau and some may know it to have
seen the film The English Patient which
goes back to one of our tradition the
English Patient in fact was last long
Alma she's to whom we still have a lot
of direct relation and of course the
film The English Patient wasn't taking
short they are close to the Libyan
border but in Hollywood and and Tunisia
in some easier places but there you have
what was what Almaty or the English
Patient called the swimmers cave where
you have depictions of apparently
swimming swimming people in the middle
of the desert where today there's less
than 2 millimeters of rainfall on an
average which forms part of of the rock
art in this cave and on this radar image
you can see that it's in fact there were
really fluvial system drainage patterns
existing during the the period first
half of the Holocene eleven to five
thousand years ago more or less which
originated directly at the foot of this
cave of swimmers and reason just a few
years ago some Italian tourists
explorers found another cave nearby
which is probably the single most rich
richest single a break in the earth of
this era where you have more than ten
thousand a single depictions ranging
from two millimeters to to more than two
meters depicting some some monster like
features and also depicting some
swimming people person apparently and
and all kinds of other a detail
which tell a story about the prehistoric
life in this remote place when the
Sahara or was was rather savanna then a
desert and you know there's in many
paintings and engravings which may be
connected to them much much later out
during the pharaonic Empire on the other
end there still lots of room of
speculation and we you normally prefer
to get some firm evidence before
venturing into too much demanding
hypotheses on the origin there's a book
which our and each part is institute
edited recently it's five kilogram so I
couldn't bring it but it's a it's
probably the largest rock art
documentation of a single site well to
my knowledge so not too far away is what
he barked and usually we give our own
names because there's no patrons you
could call for local name so we always
turn most of the sites ourselves this is
a Playa Lake like in the southwestern
states of today which once had a quite
impressing surface water surface which
was formed because the water was blocked
by a by a format UN which closed the
entire valley and only some 7,000 years
ago the dams is doomed and broked and so
through a natural gap the water drained
and since then there was no more a
communication accumulation of deposits
which are their only basis for for
climate reconstruction geologists have
and that's one of the sections and where
you see that you see F each and every
single major rainfall event recorded in
some tiny sand layers and if you get
radiocarbon dating you get more detailed
information on the distribution of
sexual rain events over the millennia in
this hyper
core present-day hyper-arid core of C
Eastern Sahara which had rainfall up to
150 millimeters per year compared to
less than 2 millimeters today and
although these deposits are connected to
the change in the prehistoric life and
economy so another interesting point is
which I would just mention shortly that
it's not the average rainfall per year
which is important but rather see the
distribution of the paler rainfall that
means some monsoon all summer daytime
rainfall has led much less impact on the
growth of vegetation than else is very
Thai a very light winter night night
time rains which occur during the later
period which bro provided for much more
grassland and much more pasture than in
the earlier date that means sometimes
the the data from geology and archeology
are canta canta
contradictory until you resolve the
puzzle so another example is what was
once the largest paleo lake in in in the
Eastern Sierra what we called West
Nubian paleo Lake and what you see here
is not the backbone of a gazelle but the
backbone of a Nile perch which used to
live in in this place where today no
scorpion can survive with a length of
almost two yards and some places are not
covered by windblown sand and with the
old Landsat one data we had there was
practically nothing to be seen but it
used to be a very large lake with full
of fauna that means within five minutes
you could collect such a collection of
fish bones and crocodile bones and hippo
bones etc etc and also we found some
turquoises and these dirt was is have
been the last proof that probably what
we rediscovered and called it West
moving Pele in fact corresponds with
Thole mean marshes of Socotra seeds
which are recorded in the written
sources but by ptolemy and where the
geology present-day geology well could
also locate these lakes which were not
known before and and this what looks
like today must should have looked like
present-day Chet today a very large but
very shallow freshwater lake and of
course once there's water there are
three storage settlements and what looks
like this today including cattle burials
and all kinds of archaeological with all
kinds of archeological features probably
looked like this when the early cattle
were used by this by the people living
around this lake and again very short
sometimes settlement sets on only after
the maximum lake extension has gone
because who likes to settle in a marsh
which is infested by crocodiles and and
malaria mosquitoes and so on that
usually only once these lakes is paler
lakes became smaller that people
approach while the surrounding
environments were no more good for
living so they were approaching this
remaining lakes until they finally
disappeared but as example is one which
is to the present day practically the
least explored part of Sahara if not of
Africa and this is in the extreme north
eastern a corner of what is today the
Republic of chart only one has a name
Bay try to cross it riding in front of
his Caravan on a white horse but he was
guided of course by them guys from from
Kufra in the southern Libyan Oasis route
Chapel who a knot and then he crossed it
but he was riding at night
so there's practically nothing left of
his his first transect through this area
and he would have died of thirst if say
if the year before wouldn't have been a
rainy one exceptional rainy one and so
they found a character was water and
that's the way they made it into
sub-saharan every
so that was one trip with it in 2005 on
this LD ma which is as unknown as a GILF
kabir plateau which I've been showing
before was 120 years ago that means
there has never ever been any scientific
research and or even any other visitor
to to the written knowledge and it's
it's a high escarpment these are cars
for scale where you first have to find
your way up even there Google doesn't
help too much sometimes you're driving
again on on apparently a sandy surfaces
which in fact are just a small windblown
cover on whether fluvial and Lake form a
paleo Lake deposits and this is a dust
which in the end nourishes the Amazonian
rainforest because this dust which
originates in the in chart today is
transported over the Atlantic and
provides all the minerals necessary for
the survival of tropical rainforest and
that's typical landscape it's like the
surface on marsh down into detail really
from millimeter scale to tens of killed
kilometer scale there are it's very
similar so this is probably the best
inelegant for the landforms on mars on
planet earth and there are some in the
northeast parts exist like this way you
could have a 360 degree view which would
look all the same and at this specific
position 19 1/2 degrees north 23 degrees
east is what used to be the triangular
junction between the three empires of
france england and italy and that was
why this small stone cairn was erected
by the only known Marist soldier two
soldiers who were sent there to mark the
border of the three European empires in
37 so we didn't find it we found it
later but they did a very good job units
many kilometers away from the GPS
position of course
and I was showing this to show that that
place is like the LD Molitor where there
is practically nothing
there are almost no prehistoric
settlement site there is there are no
Paleo Lake that means this plateau must
have been what it is still today because
air demand means the enemy's country and
this has been also depicted like that
since historical writings and even if
today if you would run into someone and
probably you could they stayed there for
many years without meeting a single
person but if then for sure this would
be bandits or rebels while surrounding
of the edema you have since its virgin
sites which consists of this grinding
tools and many many other archeological
material and that's for sure that not
even any Bedouin has passed at this
location during the past five thousand
years because he certainly would have
taken this maracas its grinding tool for
his wife at home in his village for for
regular daily use so that was my team of
this first scientific exploration of
this part of the world and now I'm
taking you to another part of chart in
northeastern chat the energy plateau
which is a triangular least escape
sandstone plateau
it's like a big labyrinth so ninety
percent are completely unknown to the
present day and probably will still take
a generation to explore all these
thousands and thousands of miles of box
canyons a hidden in this plateau the
size of Switzerland more than thirty
thousand square kilometers or maybe one
day mass type robots who will do the job
and the first mentioning of the sites
was by Gustav Nachtigal one of the early
German explorers who did the basic
research in chart but even articles
inspired his five-year travel didn't
make it there but he collected all the
information by the local people at the
time and was describing it quite well
though the bore the surrounding
escarpment looks like this in many
places you have real labyrinths which to
me
really the origin of the tales of 1001
night was a labyrinth where camera can
hardly goes through and so on a to the
detail and this is a reason drones view
from a clip we we prepare to for UNESCO
recently where you see that you really
can get lost if there's a dust storm GPS
doesn't work because you don't have
satellite access you can really die of
thirst if you lose yourself inside so
even today you have to take care and
some places resemble very much to the
Monument Valley but they are much more
distributed and much bigger you have
some of the highest Rock arches on the
globe you have for example this mushroom
rocks which indicate the former former
land surface and this is evidence of
millions of sandstorms who have taken
everything in the lower two meters away
you have all kinds of other interesting
interesting sandstone pillars etc and
you have a lots of vegetation especially
in its western valleys because of the
higher elevation which collects some
monsoon rain froze still coming from the
Gulf of Guinea and trend transversing a
big part of sub-saharan Africa to reach
there so that's why it has been called
the garden Eden of the Sahara which is a
sort of relict area which is a good
comparison for the situation during the
green Sahara 11,000 to 5,000 years ago
you also have some some very small
entrances to to Gore church which
sometimes open up to Cathedral like
structures where you find trees and and
and and birds and water and so on and
you have the famous ghost I say we're
still the last remaining crocodiles in
all of the Sahara the last remaining
crocodiles which have survived five
thousand years of aridity which once
came from the from the Nile
going along the body our to reach the
energy mountains and the last
populations now they are seven
and there's against all the forecasts of
all biologists there's a new newborn
crocodile one which got out of an egg
last year so even sometimes a minimum
populations good enough for proliferates
that's right word so you hear you
probably see nothing at all but if you
look closer you'll find this - Barbary
sheep move laws which are still living
in this place which I extinct in most
places of the Sahara you also still
finds lots of other animals which which
are completely distinct extinct anywhere
else in Zara and we met people who have
never seen a white person in their life
never seen a Western or European in
their life who live in very remote
places on top of the plateau and once
they say got to know that we wouldn't do
them any harm they were very friendly
that happens to the present day in the
Sahara people have never seen any white
person and most famous of all is the
rocket of the entity which in my view
surpasses any other rock outsides of
which there are few in the Sahara
including the Tassili a chair in the
uncounted a breeze and cave there and
suddenly which gave a very clear almost
photographic impression of prehistoric
life in this in this mountainous area
during the time and you already can see
some some details as it is but once
you're applying some color enhancing
methods and you see much more you can
really find details on the dress of
women had the type of dance when they
went out for a party or whatsoever taken
from into details on the hut - - how
they had their dresses etc many many
many other details which are hidden
there and which really give direct
insight in in this prehistoric way of
life
nine thousand to two thousand years ago
more or less and this is all natural
colours which survived uncounted hours
of insulation heavy insulation
insane storms and so on and they are
still there but the most important
animal depicted were the cows which
apparently had a much bigger
significance to prehistoric people than
then elephants or giraffes or hippos or
rhinos and so on and in the late
appeared during the Iron Age you had
typically the sort of horse rider until
the camel people arrived around 2,000
years ago because cameras were
introduced into this era only about
2,000 years ago by the after the Persian
invasion of Egypt and there you see all
that the first snakes coming up and
normally this this chemist painted
overlay of earlier rock art such as
these horses or the the cattle and
sometimes on top of the of these camels
which the more recent historic appeared
you still find to you to pick up with
some Kalashnikov attached on top and
this is the most recent rock art dating
from the 1950s when there was the onset
of modern modern cars in this part of
the Sahara we might even have found the
first comic but that would be enough for
another one but depending whether you
read it from left to right or vice versa
it tells a different story and so we go
to another two with two body Hauer which
once was the largest tributary to to the
Nile from the Sahara linking the central
jardian basin of Lake chart with the
Nile well in a westerly easterly
direction so it was a large river up to
ten kilometers wide and the lower part
was five hundred kilometers long and had
really a super regional importance for
the southeastern sahara and that's how
it looks today if you're lucky and you
find some windows with some exposed
river deposits and you even find people
who drowned in this deposit that's not a
barrier there apparently too
des was practically 520 millimeters of
rainfall
there were people drowning in cyst
deposits like this gentleman which was
dated to around 7,000 years ago and this
place once you look into the deposits
which looks like this today has looked
into detail like a site in North and
Kordofan or Western therefore as it
looks today and everything you see on
this picture from the deposits to the
bird bones we found in the deposits in
this place and that's how it looks in
some other places where you found in in
such places high energy freshwater
oysters which you find today in the
cataracts along the Nile Valley but
certainly no more anywhere in the Sahara
or jaws of elephants or exotic minerals
like this realistic work any garage
which indicate that there was a long
long range fluvial transport until a few
thousand years ago and you have probably
the most ancient rock art at all at
least in northern sudan where you find
this herds of rhinos which are normally
solitary and living animals with with
peaceful who's peaceful people in
between so this is to me really some
sort of impression from this early form
of early Paradise which is depicted at
this single rope outside and yeah buddy
how and of course archaeology is a
nightmare
you have square miles large sites which
have a cultural lay up to one meter in
depth that means it takes a few weeks
just to excavate a few square yards not
to think of square mile that means these
are the largest prehistoric sites which
even more expanded than any prehistoric
site along the Nile Valley but they will
certainly never ever be excavated and
there are every single piece you find
here consists of pottery or bone remains
because this is the on top of a dune
worse for physical reasons
there is not any other material to be
expected
so we also found the largest and only
big construction we ever found during
the past 40 years which is a fortress a
diameter 150 yards with was up to 8
meters and as we know today it probably
dates back 3,000 years roms in a pattern
period but to the present day its
purpose is not well known why to
establish circle such a big fortress 100
kilometers away from the Nile and
probably of course to impress people
coming from the south or controlling any
traffic traffic transport maybe of gold
and so on but this parcel hasn't been
solved yet so just one view what we can
show from different region in in in in
in the Eastern Sierra that's how the
environment change from from from a
region with lots of lakes and temporary
rivers and then there's the Paleo Lakes
try it out until me play people had to
shift to places with near surface ground
groundwater where they could take walk
in well so as a survival strategy
strategy to survive until even that
groundwater fell too deep and that to
either to move or to die so the most
Explorer important example for the
reconstruction of paleo a climatology
are they in younger lakes to the present
day the in hyper continental position
very far from the from the nearest ocean
coast and the first exploration happened
in 1916 by some French military
geographer and that's in fact the
state-of-the-art
we had when we took up the research in
in the late 90s because the north of
chad was no more place to go there but
to go there is take some time and just
to get them made the material and the
wagon wheels there and and doing the
fieldwork at the side so far already
took almost one year of a field work and
that's why well I was lucky to do this
field work or the other we're lucky not
to take this venture but going there is
worth any trip so you must imagine you
cross the Sahara which sometimes takes
one week two weeks depending where it
comes three weeks and then you go
without singular seeing a single piece
of grass and then you arrive at the spot
and you advance in just one meter or two
meters and then you have the sight of
this inner of the largest lake surface
in the Sahara of today and where you
have still islands in in these lakes and
all kinds in the very rare moments where
there's no wind you have all kinds of
reflections and there's even and that's
another speciality we have freshwater
lakes which are a paradox on to any
every place because you know any
freshwater gets all to you within a few
years or decades at best and these are
legs which for where you to find today
in toads and and and living mollusks
which are in a direct genetic line from
the Morlocks which I exposed in the old
lake beds and you also find fish and
they sea salt whereas this freshwater
lakes occur only because of a unique
natural mechanism which consisted the
firmer Big Lake which once was of course
much much later was dissected by
encroaching dunes which made several
Lake Chamber so to say and the
groundwater and of course this Lake is
hundred percent supported by fossil
groundwater by rainfall which fell in
the early Holocene and one hundred
percent against a measured evaporation
of more than six thousand millimeters a
year which makes it another natural
extreme and the groundwater which goes
into this peripheral Lake is transported
through the dune dune bodies into the
central salt lake which works like a
gigantic evaporation pump and keeps this
mechanism going and that's why you have
fresh fresh drinking water you can use
in a place where it's it's not supposed
to be there there are other lakes in in
the western part but they are all highly
saline and the most important of it is
like you one which is the largest body
of water in the Sahara because of this
is steps of 27 meters
it's the diameter of only two miles but
because of the steps which is again
fully hundred percent depending on
fossil groundwater and the evaporation
on this lakes is equals the consumption
of European town with 1 million
inhabitants permanently and all this
tremendous loss of more than 6 meters of
water column is completely recharged by
fossil rainwater and that makes it so
exceptional but by the way you can
subscribe to this magazine freely and in
the present edition there's also an
article on it and the most important
thing for science is that when I went
there for the first time in 99 was a
small rubber boat and not even knowing
the depths of the lake and it get deep
and deep and deeper
deikun then I took a gravity car and
what you can see here that when I took
the core out you have had what we called
a raft layering that means you have one
layer for summer one layer for winter
one layer for summer one layer for
winter etc and that's the best you can
have as a paleo climatologist
because such sediments give very precise
data and information on climate change
down to us up in well a chronological
scale and you see that the top of the
course completely undisturbed and
consisting only of of algae which are
still drizzling down while we are here
together the sedimentation goes on and
provides a new record for the most tree
for the last year's and this mate was
good enough for science cover story and
to cut a long story short
the analysis of Poland data and several
other data were clearly indicating that
that there was a very gradual
desiccation of the Sahara during the
past six thousand years from a fully
developed savanna vegetation over some
sort of salient type vegetation to the
present day
2000 desert vegetation until even this
disappeared and there was nothing left
but some Oasis flora around the lake and
this is in clear contrast to the
assumption of my friend Peter who was
claiming that this arid if occasion of
this era happen very quickly within
decades and analysis detailed analysis
of this core showed that there's really
not a single year missing in this record
and that's why returns in 2010 with some
heavier equipment and working for a long
time under quite high temperatures to
extract the longest core not only of the
Sahara or MF Ricard but probably on
earth where we have sixteen meters of
this up annually laminated deposits
which I consider some sort of Rosetta
Stone for paleoclimatology of the Sahara
and there's lots of publications in the
pipeline so there's hardly any other
comparable side on this and of course
these lakes were up to 100 metres higher
than today because there is former Lake
deposits on top of the surrounding table
hills which give information on the
former extent which for example he's he
unlike you or was much much bigger than
than what's left today and apart from
science usually our counterparts in
Africa they are less interested in Paleo
climate than in mineral deposits or in
that case in initiative I took 15 years
ago to get these seas lakes listed as a
World Heritage Site and this is what's
happened that's why we be cut I got with
my colleagues decorated as
of judge by the judge and president of
all the local people and the local
hierarchy are very happy because nobody
in most Chadians have never heard about
dislikes nobody ever went there and now
they are the first first world heritage
natural sight in one of Africa's largest
country and there's already lots of
improvements for the live with daily
life of the people available to them so
a short example because I've been mostly
talking about climate environmental
change I will also give one example on
on from archeology and that's one side
we call Cha right so it's a it's a cave
in the central Egyptian plateau where
such kind of artifacts of knives were
produced by the prehistoric people real
pieces of Arts which later 500 2000 2000
years occur in the Nile Valley and if
you have such a former collection of
these artifacts in inner inland which
were excavated even hundred years ago in
the Nile Valley and you put the samples
the artifacts from the Sahara
over and you see they're really fitting
them completely but only they were a
couple of hundred years five hundred
years fifteen hundred years older and
that same applies to some sort of
typical pottery with some black rims and
so on which also occurs hundreds of
years earlier than the first first time
in the Nile Valley and there's also a
lot of other evidence on links into the
later period between that the last
ecological niches remaining in the in
what became more and more a desert the
desert as we know it today was entirely
including no time for that but possible
origins of your glyphic writing in deep
in the Sudanese desert so now you always
made it I make a short time travel
through the last eleven thousand or
fifteen thousand years
that's how it looked like say 15,000
years ago the Eastern Sahara you don't
see a single priest or excite there was
absolutely no occupation or in 35 years
we would have overlooked it but there's
really many reasons to believe that the
entire that this equals the size of
Western Europe it's more than 2 million
square kilometers not a single site
while all available all known
prehistoric sites are along the Nile
Valley of course because of Aswan rescue
Nubian salvation campaign they are
better studied here than here but
there's not a site anywhere outside
until apparently some 11,000 year the
knife well it became too overcrowded at
least that's one explanation because
they are graveyards where you still find
arrowheads and and individuals which
were apparently killed by arrowheads by
tribal fights and so on so suddenly
apparently the nine way Nile Valley
which was receiving much less than
rainfall then during the later period
was no more perfect place to live and
this changed relatively rapidly not
within the decades or within generations
but say between five hundred to eight
hundred years when monsoon rain coming
from the South Mike went north from
where it is today changing that was once
a completely unoccupied subcontinent
into a savanna that means there was no
more desert in in the strict sense it
was certainly arid to semi-arid with
rainfall below hundred fifty millimeters
always against the evaporation of 6,000
millimetres but today but you see that
the green Sahara and what is clear that
you hardly have any site left along the
Nile value by all the occupation site in
in them in what is today the Egyptian
Sahara and you have a couple of site in
in the northern northern Sudanese desa
Sahara but not in the in the part which
received most of the rainfall and again
the best explanation is that it was just
too humid too dangerous too
too unpleasant for daily living that
people pre story people will certainly
arrive from the south move northward
where that is open savannas which are
good for for grazing for hunting game
etcetera etcetera and a much better
place to live then a long temporary
river infested by all kind of unpleasant
animals and this situation states as
they serve for around 2,300 years when
there was a development not only and in
previously of pottery which is maybe
which is a sign of the so-called
Neolithic Revolution which which is
probably until maybe the electronic
revolution recently was the biggest step
forward in mankind because this is a
sign of said sedentary living with lots
of implication and later a domestication
of of grains and especially
domestication of cattle which is of
pastoralism which is a way of life which
still is is the most important one for
the rural areas of sub-saharan Africa
but anyway people were living all around
and that's a phase where only in the
North there was was some influence for
the introduction of goat and kettle wire
goat and and sheep why probably kettle
was an autochthonous invention from from
the green Sahara period and this
situation changed a 5000 about 5,300
years bc when you see that there there
was first of all a shift of settlement
sites into the south what is today the
northern Sudanese days that people were
surviving only ecological niches beat in
the plateau in dishes like on the Gulf
KP a plateau or and the Oasis depression
but in the vast basis of the Eastern
Sierra there was no more settlements and
especially what you see is that 3500 you
have hardly any
settlement site left any settlement left
in what is the western desert of Egypt
today and you have complete corridor of
settlement along the Nile Valley and and
some remaining settlers further south in
the Sahara and you see that this was
really a decisive date 7,000 years
around 7,500 years ago when there was
really the onset of the desiccation of
Sahara which went on until probably very
recently another interesting subject is
the importance of sedessa to the
pharaonic period but this would be good
for another talk when there was the
first trend Saharan expedition sent by
the Pharaoh always with a lot of most
recent and unpublished discoveries
during the past few years so again the
old picture says the era once was what
at least one quarter larger than it is
today so in spite of nine million square
kilometers it was probably 12 million
kilometers so covering much more than
one-third of the continent a relatively
sudden onset of the green Sahara a
relatively stable period of two and a
half thousand years and then a very
gradual southward retreat of the desert
marching to the situation where it is
today and again if you see if you look
to thousands of archaeological and radio
and geologically radiocarbon dates again
you see from in this graph which is a
line from north to south a relatively
simultaneous onset of settlement and
then you add this period where what we
call the formation period where people
they did a big big cultural and social
economic steps and and then 5,300 there
was the onset of the aridif occasion of
this era and the late appeared only in
ecological
ishes there was room for survival or you
had to move south
that means stay and die or maybe develop
some survival strategies for some
generation then you have to move or die
and that's what people did during all
this time and again this is maybe a
synthesis of this year all these decades
of fieldwork where again you see the
north as the trending relatively
simultaneous onset of settlement all
over this era and the gradual
desiccation of the desert and that goes
along with what we always called Egypt's
desert routes and where you have all
kinds of desert traditions which made it
into the pre-dynastic period and later
even in the dynastic time and this by my
friend and colleague Ruth Cooper was our
guiding line of our research or since
since 98 1970s and probably no more time
to read or to this but who wants to know
better can stop the stream also on but
essentially that's what I said again in
a few line and now concerning the desert
origins of the dynastic civilization
that was I mean the traditional view was
always that the origins of Egypt of the
Egyptian civilization all came from
Southwest Asia and were introduced by
some sort of superior culture but I
think this notion is more and more give
him up except by some very traditional
Egyptologists and there's lots of proof
that there was really this biggest step
into in human evolution fun from from
from hunters and gatherers to send that
sedentary people living more or less a
way of life we still do today with the
invention of the biggest adventure which
was pottery at the period which provided
for preservation of food and and other
things this was clearly happened
happening completely independently from
what was happened happening in in the
Levant in Palestine and so on and the
more most evidence shows that that
there's many technologically cultural
social economic traditions which were
invented in the West what is today's
Western Desert of Egypt in which were
introduced into the prehistoric Inferno
pharaonic cultures in the nile valley
and now again unless you claim that the
coincidence of the state of roughly 3500
bc when there was absolutely no more
room not even one niche existing niche
where you could survive in the desert
and this equals exactly the time the
origin of the Egyptian civilization then
you will probably see some climate
impact on it and maybe even a climate
control which doesn't work everywhere so
it does make a big difference if you're
in Somalia and there used to be 300
millimetres rainfall today's 200
millimetres of rainfall that doesn't
make that much but when you're in a
region where yet 150 millimeters and
later you have none this makes a big
difference and that's why we all firmly
believe that this very difficult is
Aurra which was terminated 3,500 at the
same time gave rise to the origin of the
nile valley civilizations not only in
the Nile but also not only in Egypt but
also in Sudan in the Nubian civilization
and that's why we shortened up always so
Egypt is not only at least the gift of
the Nile as already Herodotus said but
at the same time a gift of the desert
and now I thank you for your enduring to
this many slides and after a further
discussion I hope you have a good way
back
like let me sleep let's have a seat my
leg went to sleep I'm not having a
stroke or anything here I think about an
hour of thinking about that would be in
order at this point okay a quick easy
question from Jim Spaulding why don't
you helicopter into these places they're
grinding your way across an impossible
surface well it's is they too far away
and even the most modern Egyptian army
helicopter they could make it one way
but not back on the other hand
theoretically all the place where we
live where we where we do our research
is protected military area that means
getting a helicopter there even for this
is impossible and even very good us
colleagues from Flagstaff in spite of
year-long waiting they never got the
permit just to take research aircraft to
fly over the western desert so this is
certainly no option and if you have lots
of time then maybe army type rescue
mission could make it but then you
certainly would need to wait for weeks
and so far never ever in most of these
places a helicopter has been to the
present day
where have you been the last couple days
and why well when I've been to chart a
few days ago before just changing the
plane for San Francisco I've been in the
capital of jet engine inna the hottest
African capital we had temperature 45
degrees Celsius and in the beginning
rainy season that makes permanent sauna
and their the objective was to put
forward another world heritage project
to work that hopefully next year or at
least one year later the NAD plateau
will will be elected as the second world
heritage site of one of Africa
largest countries that sounds great it's
a little more they showed us some of the
stuff of that Plateau um well it becomes
a World Heritage Site is it then become
a place that some of us can go and visit
and see some of those incredible box
canyons and monument valleys and rock
art and the rest of it what happens when
it becomes a World Heritage Site or sure
well if I mean there's of course very
strictly guidelines for any World
Heritage Site and so all the host
countries because its World Heritage are
not just national heritage so they are
advised to follow it and usually taking
it's relatively easy to control the
relatively few visitors who will go
there during the next years and decades
provided such a security situation
remains stable because in contrast to
practically all all of history in North
and Chad now is the only tranquila quite
island
in within the sahara while all the other
ten sovereign states are practically no
more place to go at least not into the
desert unless you want to do some
adventure travel so are other scientists
following your path here and one of the
questions had to do is why is Germany so
particularly interested in this part of
the world and your German scientists
operating what looks like a German
scientific tradition and have forged the
way and do some amazing areas and
amazing kinds of discovery are other
scientists following now and in pursuing
these paths of research well it's
getting more and more difficult to have
to find students who are ready to go
into the field for months without
extreme it's because it's extreme group
condition you're like on a space shuttle
there's no way to have a beer one day
you're practically in the night you can
take your sleeping bag and go away from
the camp for a couple of hundred meters
we are living on five liters a day one
gallon a day which we hardly use except
when it really gets hot everything
included in the night it's very cool
daytime it's very hot you can't take a
shower for months you are separated from
your family
your friends for four months so fewer
and fewer students are ready to take
this just to do the research so what we
still so we are sort of out dying
species of this type research we have to
wait for some mass type robots who will
take the follow up and usually it's
still sometimes possible to find
students who go along once to write the
diploma thesis or the PhD and so on but
right after they switch over to remote
sensing lab work etc so shocking it's
sucking yes the younger generation of
explorers earth are wusses I would
expect you make this adventure look so
tough and incredible that you if anybody
would be attracting people who would be
coming up after talks like this saying
okay I'm changing my life I want to go
to the hardest most exciting places in
the world where really original
discoveries can be made you don't have a
lot of people being inspired to go off
and do that fitness now I have a long
long list of so-called amateurs of
laymen of people said my rock art
hunters are interested in rock art or it
went rests on our retired generals
doctor so I have a long long long list
of people with just one call one email
and I can take along 50 on one trip the
problem is this is not covered by the
German Research Council and I need to
take scientists or students to do this
kind of research and of course you need
some training and and that's the problem
so I mean there's lots of highly
enthusiastic people who pay a lot just
to follow it because we're really going
to this last unexplored little explored
a places which you can't order with some
too operator but unfortunately we need
specialists and they are difficult
enough to get and also it's it's all you
need normally it's impossible to find to
get a good team because first of all
most important is you have to have a
team which gets along for a specific
time of a period of time in extreme
group condition of course you need a
very good field researcher then you need
at the same time say a good writer who
puts it all to the tooth does the
paperwork then you need one who knows
about lab analysis
which is very important and then you
need one who does cooking who can change
cars who can sort of mechanical problems
etc etc and this list is very difficult
to complete and so even in the good old
days it was difficult to get some teams
which you could get along because well
if you have one or two and the team who
hate to do it and and you f you know you
have to you Lube they around for the
next two months you can send some home
that's rather worse what can happen and
so so the training part sounds like in a
way the the hardest field what training
do you really want and the scientists
that you would take into a place like
this what what background do they need
they have what kinds of backgrounds they
need to have to be useful now of course
it's mostly a background in geological
fieldwork and archaeological excavations
in botanical research and so on and of
course it's it's this is the profile but
at the same time one has to be ready to
take these conditions and I would say
most of at least the German soldiers
would not be ready to do this way of
life for extended period of time so it's
really a big problem
apart from academic specifications of
this kind of field research well you
know hmm with YouTube and extreme sports
and sort of the the things that people
show off I would this is more
interesting going to Mars in fact it's
pretty similar to going to Mars except
you can actually get there yes I
astonished there isn't more attraction
for highly skilled highly trained
highly courageous and highly cooperative
people who come and find their way onto
these expeditions so get with it people
question in your 40 years of exploring
the deep Sahara have you ever visited
the same location during the same time
of year and found differences or is the
main event that nothing changes
oh it changes I mean it's a highly
dynamic environment all deserts and even
if you go to a specific location during
different time of the day in the morning
at midday in the evening you see
different things because of the light
which comes from different angles
sometimes you go in the morning you'll
find nothing but fish remains in midday
you find plenty of meteorites and in the
evening you find plate plenty of pottery
fragments all around just depending on
the light which gets there and of course
because of the ever shifting sand
sometimes places I exposed which are
covered the next day sometimes covered
four thousand years as that which moved
forward for example before once found a
dinosaur skeleton in the wind what
direction of this big crescentic Park on
dunes I when I tried came with some
specialist five years later this week
when Tomita I back on dunes weighing two
hundred thousand tons was over it so it
would need to have to wait a couple of
hundred years until it moves fine so
it's not just a matter of returning
there but you always find new things and
some things you overlooked and so on and
wasn't there's never discovered
something in front of a bark on doing
discovery things are being revealed by
the pain is moving on poets for example
we found off of one of say of paeonia
explorers Rob Peck not who I still got
to know who died or almost thirty years
ago and we found for example his some of
his camps in 1930 was a whiskey bottle
of whiskey with a piece of Times
newspaper and this was covered by the
by this - again taken and 5060 years
later we found the campsite and so we
could calculate the speed of the dunes
dune right advance really and the
newspaper was readable it's what's
reasonable it's a very try because
unless in the tropical realm so
everything which is its try there's no
animals not even termites who could eat
it so usually what you find there it
stays like it is and until the erosion
time fired by the wind removes it
completely imagine the whiskey bottle
looked kind of jobs good is that right
yeah
she kept ours so the desert is telling
this long-term story of that that you've
dissected in great detail and and
there's a flux and we see similar things
in the stories of the ice coming and
going in the north and here the rains
coming and going in North Africa what's
your sense of in that sort of long
oscillation how it plays out over the
next 10,000 years
to come up with a round number that we
like a lot well exactly I mean that's
not politically correct what I'm going
to answer to your question I like it
well generally according I mean most
paleo climatologists agree that the the
past climate history was mostly
controlled by by astronomical factor
that means the so called Milankovitch
curves and the insulation on on what is
today north and africa during the pre
pre preceding two and a half million
years when there was one humid face more
or less every hundred thousand years
that was quite a regular cycle of course
with some changes and for example the
preceding wet face is so-called Eemian
or isotopic marine as a topic age five
that was probably much more important
than the last the early Holocene
Green Sahara and it was much longer but
this was his trend and so normally I
would say well the last glacial maximum
happened some 25,000 years ago that
means we would have to wait for the next
period of a green Sahara reunion of the
Sahara some 60,000 years this would be
the natural cycle now since the late 88
1980s I I found in this remote places
where there is no human use not even by
Bedouins or the by the camels or goats
there is a clear trend for a very slow
onset of a sort of regrading at the
southern margin of what is today the
desert a regrading that means Sagara
sees as increasing rainfall which
produces more grass land which then
attracts camel people who came first
time in generations much further north
and then animal are some birds arrived
mice arrived snakes arrived we even seen
an ostrich and so on and the gazelles a
multiply so there's really a clear trend
of course you can only see it once you
go to places which without any which are
not used for grazing or not on so that's
what everybody is talking about the
encroachment of the desert this is only
well it around the big cities and now
imagine for example the food had a
population of 1 million inhabitants in
the 1950s now we're approaching 10
Millions within 60 years and of course
once you're approaching the big cities I
mean that that's all desert land there's
no more trees there's nothing but once
you go to places which is far away
there's an opposite trend and so I get
insulted as some sort of climate sceptic
because it's caused just because I say
there's always winners and losers and
which is very bad for the Bangladeshi
may be good to see sub-saharan Sahelian
zone or even for the old sub
sup desert zone of the old world desert
which reaches from the Atlantic into
central China and this is I would say if
this continues its a positive trend but
again this doesn't meet everybody has to
buy a high-powered vehicle just to speed
up the process but the trend seems to be
there and well it's now for 25 years
that it can't be denied there's more and
more remote sensing studies and also
other arguments which now follow this
early suggestion so it's been going on
25 years and he showed me a photographic
earlier in the green room he showed me a
photograph of a piece of desert which
would be the most boring place on Mars
it's flat nothing and then another year
the same place whereas absolutely
verdant with it looks like flowers the
forbs with grass with a little shrub
like stuff and so on
people did not seed that so that
suggests to me that in that that totally
desiccated desert there was a seed bank
of plant seeds just waiting patiently
for a bit of rain how long do they have
to wait can apparently wait hundreds of
years and of course sometimes that
normally the dominating winds 95% of the
trade winds coming from the north but
there of course I'm rare subtly winds
which then into the present day can
bring seeds far into the desert and then
it just needs some real rainfall and and
you have within days and weeks you have
a cover coverage and this doesn't apply
only to the eastern zahra my Sahabi
friends from the from the western part
of the sahara my chart and friends in
north my sudanese friends i mean every
part you go see a-- telling the same
story they can't believe it every year
to say it has never been that greens an
exercise has never been that green but
of course only there where there's
hardly any human being once it's used
and you just have have to you would have
to make a fence around it and you would
get a recurring Bell which is being done
these days of trying this make this
green wall on the southern border of the
Sahara it's a big project which already
has started quite well which one day
she'll make a fenced area from the
Atlantic to the Red Sea and to show and
to first to prevent winds encroach a
sand encroachment but also to to make a
natural green wall against the desert
and this is if this trend continuous it
certainly this is somebody's fantasy ORS
this is a scheme that the various
nations across that part of Africa or
collaborating it's a scheme
theoretically all sub-saharan states
collaborating of course sometimes have
other problems and I'm not talking about
the increasing insecurity in sorry it
has never been so difficult to do
fieldwork in this era like today that
means our paradise of fools where we
could do what we like for decade this is
gone probably forever
and because nobody will take away the
small-arms nobody will take away the GPS
and and the land mines and so on so this
is there to be almost forever I'm afraid
and so the scheme is officially this is
this grand project of greening that band
of Africa there's a science-fiction book
called dune okay Frank River that comes
to mind of desert people you know taking
generations to with a grand vision of
how they can revitalize that case their
planet in this case an entire area of an
amazing continent anyway this is
extraordinary vision in it you know
apart from helping with this kind of
exploration one wants to wonder are
there ways to help that scheme to you
know help the rege reigning of that part
of
long on green Africa they may be help
with restoring not only the plant life
at the biodiversity that presumably goes
with that point life if it's allowed to
is that also a part of this fantasy it
sure is so I think that really the the
major problem again politically
uncorrect is the exponential population
growth in sub-saharan Africa I think
with a stable population say that of the
1950s I think there would already be a
very positive trend recognized by all
the people living there but of course
this is a very sensitive subject in all
religions and and which is ignored but
in the in the fact many many problems
from tough were to anywhere they're all
related to this for the lack of natural
resources compared to the
ever-increasing population everywhere
and that's the major problem which is
there's no way for any solution in the
next time I had I'm afraid
well back to exploration arena asked you
found so much is there anything you're
looking forward to in this region region
[Laughter]
that you want to explore that you want
to find that you think are important
discoveries kinds of discoveries yet to
be made what's still out there
Oh uncountable I mean there's still four
generations of field research I mean for
example the northern part of jetties as
I think I mentioned this s unknown at
southwestern each of this plateau was
120 years ago they means there's still a
big big before hundred years ago only a
hundred years ago there was hard it was
discovered only later means ninety years
ago even the same situations in north
and in northern chart where you still
have unhidden treasures I mean it's no
way not to find anything if you know
what you're looking for in the Sahara it
says some people go there they said or
what the archaeology telling about all
this artifact we spent there
we never found anything once you know a
bit and you only see what you know once
you note for example years we didn't
find fish bones as parts of this Nile
perch for example once we knew to
recognize we found them everywhere same
applies to met rites whose pottery to
artifacts to to many many many other
things my Crowley's tiny things has been
no matter where your car breaks down or
you have to change the tire you get off
and you find something
so even sometimes in the night when
you're looking you're always looking and
I hate to sleep right at the campsite
because someone snoring some parts
moving and so on so always in the night
I take my sleeping bag and my sake and
go a couple of hundred metres away from
the camp upwind and so find a find a
site
I find I found a place to put my my
mattress and my sleeping bag and in
night I wake up and I look to my right
looking for my torch what do I have in
hand is surely an ant eggs which can be
500,000 years ago I look I look at the
other side again I don't find my torch
have another is surely in hand eggs and
the next morning I look around the hand
axes are really concentrated at this
specific site where it's protected from
the wind by some sort of in the burgh
pipe I buy some buy buy some rock
obstacle that means some prehistoric
hunters and gatherers 500 400 300 years
ago had the same problem of looking for
campsite in the night where they didn't
get the heavy chill factor and so it's
it's still unbelievable much too far the
biggest part of the rock art for example
in the chapel hour not in this triple
junction between Libya and Egypt and
Sudan which we are also trying to get to
make it into a trance pounder in a
tional Park was discovered only two in
the past 10 years
I mean in many many other places also
still unlimited scope for discoveries in
these places and I didn't couldn't touch
upon this ancient pharaonic trails in
sutras are
which which are highly interesting
subjects is first trends are in highways
because at enduring pharaonic old and
middle Empire it was there were no
camels of course so any expeditions into
what was already a full developed desert
you bonded highly logistic skills and so
on because you had to transport your
water with donkeys where you needed
hundreds of donkeys just to get there
with the water which we then could use
as sort of payload and so on this and
there's lots of interesting discoveries
and I'm I think that this these
expeditions which were sent by the
Pharaohs into the desert where we also
already found some really thick
inscriptions in a line that they were
heading for the for the nad plateau and
for the own younger lakes which to the
earlier time must have been real as you
provisional importance as so certainly
the followers all the heard about it and
wanted to get everything which blooming
African environment could provide ok so
here these guys are on the Nile or a
long way from those lakes and are they
and they're hitting on that direction
looking for the lakes freshwater lakes
full fish and stuff but it's a long way
off
so is it stories that they're hearing if
there's these lakes out there that the
occasional individual who somehow
getting across and saying there's lakes
where I just was how would they know
about something that far away that they
would do expeditions toward it it's a
very good question because of course the
Egyptians traditionally twosome present
they are very very much a threat of the
desert everything bad always comes from
the desert today either
BB's the locusts or bees and storms or
be bandits or later the Libyan so we had
some we had some Egyptian colleagues
with us because the archaeologists
always have to take a sort of inspector
with them and when he came with us one
of us versus 35 years he was never
leaving the car he was because all his
coolies like nobody
ever returned alive from the guilt
Scabbia I mean we spent one or two
months in the desert when we returned
and we hit the first tracks and then we
hit the first paved road he went out
praying for one hour because he was a
new life that means that's a typical
standard and now a matching in the past
probably there was the same story that
most of the night dwellers everything
bad came from the desert nobody was at
the land of the dead and in many many
horrific writings
it's described off of the place and well
you wouldn't find any good but then to
sent expeditions there long missions
which took months into a direction
probably could only have were only
possible with some support with some
local knowledge by maybe the last tough
guys who remained anyway anyhow in this
remote desert maybe some very very lost
ecological niches and so and they
probably worth were used as guides we
never had any guides because in the
Eastern Zahra there are no guides
available because all people left 5,000
years ago and and so we always had to be
our guides but in most other parts of
cesare of course different lines but it
was five thousand years ago yeah but at
that time you didn't need any guides
because was a lots of other stuff
but anyway and so probably say depended
on some local knowledge from some tough
guys who let them where they met and
these people coming from sub-saharan
Africa's exchanging their goods and so
on one final story tell me about the
Persian army that headed into the desert
well that's another of the mysteries of
the Libyan desert after an extent that
there was a Persian general called
campuses or calm biases
this is window century that that was
some 500 BC okay and he what is known
that he went along down the knife well
he went west apparently and there the
last
records that he reached was only there's
Egyptians all along yoli sorry yeah
exactly that's why when you handle
well he already was the posing of camera
so that was a big advantage and and so
he probably made it into the new well II
and the OSS depression west of the Nile
and he was heading for the Siva which
was the site of Alexander's Oracle and
so on which was a tricky thing a friend
of mine Klaus Coleman who excavated for
years but another story across to the
northwest use a great sense II of Egypt
which consists of these thousand
kilometers long longitudinal Jews up to
100 meters high which are very difficult
to cross by by camels that means because
they have steep angles and so on
anyway he never showed up in in Siva but
he left our system pression so according
to different sources which range from
five thousand to fifty thousand he got
drowned by the sand somewhere hit by
some sand storm and but there are some
hints on this Persian armies consisting
of old stone cans which we found some
Persian pottery in some sites but that's
all what is known and even to penetrate
through tens of meters of sands is even
with modern means a very difficult task
so still way for an undulation mystery
it's your job to find out what happened
in army thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you